[Music]
welcome back to peterborough censored
breaking news tonight the queen after
such an amazing day uh the start of
platinum jubilee celebrations has sadly
tonight announced that she will not be
attending the thanksgiving service of
course in her honor for her 70-year
reign at some pools cathedral tomorrow
she will however be lighting the first
beacon for the beacon uh which is going
to roll out across across the the
country so i'm hoping that means she's
not too bad it just means she can't
travel at the moment because windsor
castle to some balls is quite a hike at
96 when you've got mobility issues and
clearly suffering some discomfort as the
palace has said in their statement well
i'm joined now in the studio by
vancantus hitchingbrook julie montague
author of the new royals and world
commentators kelly nicholl from manatee
fair and kinsey scover welcome to you
kinsey you were so excited to see me
earlier i thought i would double your
excitement and bring you from the fox
studio to here so welcome thank you so
much i am a huge fan well i'm a big fan
of yours too now so that's two of us um
what does just start with you k d
vermeil uh this is not good news
whichever way we try and dress this up
for the queen to miss the big
thanksgiving service she's a big church
girl a big believer which is the head of
the church yeah so it's important for
her not to be there is a big deal what
are we reading to this okay so i'm going
to preface it by saying it is a shock i
know of people tuning in this evening
and thinking oh gosh you know this is
not good it's not great but
when i came on your show a few weeks ago
i said to you i was told by a source
close to the royals that nothing was
certain yes because as you pointed out
she really wasn't very well so the fact
that we've had two balcony appearances
today the lighting of the beacons this
evening i think suggests there's no need
for alarm bells to be ringing however
it's going to look very strange and as
soon as i heard that news i thought do
you remember in 2012 and the duke of
edinburgh wasn't at that service of
thanksgiving and how strange it felt
and i just think when you take away the
queen from a service of thanksgiving to
thank for her life it's going to look
very strange well also it's a little bit
um sort of curse this event now julie
because we've already had the archbishop
of canterbury pull out because he got
covered he was supposed to be
officiating prince andrew whose
appearance in itself was going to be
very controversial i think uh because
last time he appeared with the queen was
at prince philip's funeral and people
didn't really like it the fact that she
was appearing to sort of accept him back
into public life so he was due to be
there but he's also tested positive for
kovid so there's a lot going on there is
it's going to look very empty i think
tomorrow at the service because now the
queen won't be there prince andrew it
won't be there as well and i do think
that there might be a you know that
moment of awkwardness because then you
have harry and megan coming and we know
that they obviously uh still have a
great relationship as they say with the
queen but the queen will be missing so i
think
there's going to be this moment of you
know intense in there
exactly who are they going to be sitting
next no question i was told by a very
good source it was pretty tense today
that behind the scenes apparently there
was some disquiet from palace officials
that megan and harry turned up
apparently 15 minutes late not for the
actual start of the parade but 15
minutes later they were supposed to and
apparently it was all quite frosty
behind the scenes and the rest of the
family went out in the garden and were
milling around and they just disappeared
so there's already a lot of tension
there and the only glue it seems in this
whole tension is the queen absolutely
and she's now not going to be there so
we're going to have a bit of a drama
tomorrow morning potentially in a church
where there aren't many of them and the
ones who are going to be there don't get
on i agree and i think that it's really
important to the queen that the family
is united i think it's important to her
because she's concerned about prince
charles and she wants everybody to
accept him and she wants there to be
healing and peace so i i i'm concerned
about tomorrow yeah i mean look let's
just hope it all goes peacefully and
well but it's it's not looking
particularly good is it giving all
that's been going on i just want to go
through
some of my heart as i was right there at
the palace today covering it for fox in
america and it was very moving the whole
day it was very inspiring it felt me
very proud to be british actually i have
to say it showed the country at its best
it was a beautiful sunny day and the mao
was absolutely teeming the atmosphere
was fantastically positive so after all
the
mayhem of the pandemic and given that
the country is ravaged by inflation at
the moment many people are really
feeling the pinch it was a great
celebration of what it is good to be
british and i love that um but there
were some heroes and villains today
inevitably the villains were led by
radical vegans who decided to try and
ruin the party by throwing themselves
over railings and lying pretending to be
dead on the floor in front of some of
the uh the military as they went by they
were immediately flat-lined by i think
meat-eating police officers
um i don't know what it is with vegas
other than they're permanently angry and
dare i suggest they're hangry because
they're never having a good meal and
this is what happens when you don't eat
a balanced diet you literally go nuts so
they try to ruin it they got removed
in my heroes category you can't get past
little louie who's kate and williams
youngest who basically spent his entire
time on the balcony pulling faces um we
did a montage of his greatest hits from
the daily mail i think this uh
absolutely spectacular although i did
caption it is this the moment auntie
megan arrived
um probably the reaction of most of the
royals so that was most certainly in the
thing i'm talking of auntie megan um she
she was caught of course she was caught
because she was going to make sure she
was through the balcony for the troop in
the color so this is the behind the back
of the palace that balcony it was very
much appropriately the reserve balcony
um which is where she found herself
along with being in an outhouse rather
than the primary balcony and this is her
having the audacity to tell the young
royals to shush
because they've been yapping too much
this from the greatest yapper in the
history of modern monarchy so a little
ironic if you don't mind me saying um
were you silenced or were you were you
silenced or were you silenced was i
silent or was i silenced exactly yeah it
made me chuckle anyway whichever way you
look at it i'm joined also by royal
biographer tom bowie uh he's in central
london tom and you've just written a
book about the duchess of sussex um
don't want to dwell on her too much i do
want to ask you about the queen because
it was a very you know it was a
wonderful day but it already felt to me
quite bittersweet as it was because i i
just felt look at this woman she's 96
we're not going to have another jubilee
for her unless she lives to be 106 which
is unlikely so this is really the last
chance to say a proper thank you and and
celebrate her reign and her life and it
was all magnificent but then tonight we
get this sting in the tail that she
can't attend this and paul's
service which i know will be a huge blow
to her because she is the head of the
church
well you're right it's uh it is very
disappointing uh but on the other hand
on the plus side piers it does mean that
uh netflix won't get the panning shot of
megan to the queen
and that'll really annoy netflix
enormously so there's always a bit of a
rainbow i mean on that on that tom i
have to ask you i mean you know my my
big objection to harry and megan is
primarily the the rampant hypocrisy that
accompanies almost everything that comes
out of their mouths
and we saw this acutely when they keep
preaching about the environment and
about the need to save our carbon
footprint and then we discover they got
here from california on a private jet
i mean when they do things like that
who buys this nonsense who who lets them
behave like this and thinks this is
actually good
well you get excited about that i get
excited about megan appearing in this
extraordinary hat with a big smile and
letting down the window of her car so
she can be seen yeah i mean here is a
woman who as you know better than anyone
else
according to you lied 17 times on the
opera show interview and hasn't yet
apologized right and why has she come
here has you come here to apologize to
the queen has you come here to say that
she's sorry to the duchess of cambridge
or is she here to promote herself
and i thought her big smiles as she
edged towards the window to make sure
that the camera should see her with her
oversized hat was all part of the
promote megan show
yeah that's really quite extraordinary i
thought well it is extraordinary and
what it's worth yeah and it is
it chips away i think the magic of the
monarchy because they've already got
this huge problem with prince andrew and
there's no doubt that scandal's been
very very damaging to the brand of the
monarchy the fact that the queen's
second son has had to write this huge
check for millions of dollars to
basically pay off a woman who was taking
him to court over a serious sexual
assault charge that is unprecedented in
modern times for the monarchy and in
very damaging thing but i also think
what you're seeing this turmoil uh
turmoil we're now seeing on in the
commonwealth in the many countries
i think you can directly chart a lot of
it back to the oprah winfrey interview
where meghan markle made these serious
allegations of racism against the royals
but didn't actually say who she was
talking about thereby
almost bringing them all into the frame
and i think you're seeing the the
kickback from that
absolutely now in my book forthcoming
book which is out next month i explained
very digitally in detail how the
cambridge's visit to jamaica
was predestined to be difficult if not
disastrous because the effect of megan
and the racist allegations she made
there's no doubt that across the
caribbean across other parts of the
world megan's allegations of racism
resounded and had a terrible effect on
the image of the queen on the image of
britain and the royal family and to see
her then smiling through the window of a
car and when she'd let down the window
and standing close to make sure that she
should be seen in the
horse girls parade today without any
contrition whatsoever just shows what a
brazen husky she is yeah
well your words not mine but i'm not
denying them um
let's let's just come to katie for a
moment uh about
the main event today was the queen and
it was spectacular there i mean i really
did feel moved by it what did you feel
you've covered the royals for a long
time what did you feel and it felt very
special i was commentating for the bbc
so i was in a little commentary box with
jamie louder pinkerton and um and hugh
edwards and it was it was an incredible
experience i mean nothing beats that
balcony moment i think there is a sense
you know a jubilee is as much about
looking forward to the future as it is
in being in the present and celebrating
the present and also reflecting on the
past i think there is a sense of what to
come this feels like a final hurrah for
the queen and i think for all of us even
you know regimental men of jamie louder
pinkerton status there was a lump in the
throat and that is because
she instills this the pride that you're
talking about i don't think you have to
be
a royalist um but
to appreciate what someone has done over
the course of 70 years i agree she is a
remarkable johnny rotten actually from
the sex pills was famous he sang god
save the queen as an anarchy song to get
rid of the monarchy even he said this
week on my show that he has great
respect for the queen personally which
says it all i think um julie we've got
some clips here these are world leaders
paying tribute to the queen president
biden president obama and president
macron listen to this is it quite
telling i think
your majesty congratulations on your
platinum jubilee
for 70 years you've inspired people with
your selfless devotion and service to
the people of the united kingdom and the
commonwealth on behalf of the people of
the united states we send you our best
wishes to you and the people around the
world marking this momentous and
historic occasion
you are the golden thread that binds our
two countries the proof of the
unwavering friendship between our
nations we are grateful for your courage
and we share the respect and love that
british people and commonwealth have
always shown you i'd like to think her
majesty and i have formed a special
relationship of our own
certainly i can say that getting to know
her was one of the great privileges of
my years in office
and i learned so much from seeing the
example she set for all of us who had
the privilege to serve
i mean julie this reminds me of all the
british prime ministers who said exactly
the same kind of stuff they're all
slightly in aura of the queen even
donald trump the least humble man in the
history of the planet even he admitted
to being slightly humble when he met her
because his mum had been such a great
fan of the queen
you know put her into some kind of
historical context yeah i mean i think
you can you can look at sort of the
dalai lama it's it's um somebody who
unites and doesn't divide and especially
with the turbulence that we've all
experienced over the past couple years
with of course brexit and then pandemic
uh trump uh you know who is very
divisive she's always remained this
person who wants to unite and so for me
she does have this this ability to do
that and it does remind me of somebody
like the dalai lama who is about
compassion and kindness and i think
that's what she will be remembered yes i
agree i totally agree and i felt that
with the crown today it didn't matter
what your politics were because the
queen isn't political so by turning up
you're not making a political point
because she doesn't he's not interested
in that she wants to bring the people of
britain together whatever your political
persuasions um kinsey what does she mean
to americans the queen and what do they
feel about the next
wrong on the ladder charles and camilla
i mean we absolutely adore the queen she
is selfless and i think that we really
admire her dedication to service because
we don't see that a lot in america we're
very like shallow and selfish sorry for
meghan markle because i feel like there
might be some association there but um i
think there is concern over prince
charles and camilla because americans
take the crown as complete 100 percent
facts which by the way is not a good
idea yes right these are real people
they're not fictitious characters in a
in a drama for netflix in fact what
netflix should do is do a real one on
the sussing city originals yeah exactly
yeah and i i do think that they we still
love princess diana truly we still love
her and we're we still remember her yeah
well it's great to see you all thank you
very much final word to tom bow if he's
still there
indeed tom just just point like to put
the queen into history for me because i
believe she's the greatest monarch we've
ever had followed by elizabeth the first
and then queen victoria what say you
well i'm not a great expert on every mod
we've ever had appears but in our
lifetime clearly but you know uh before
uh queen victoria there were people like
henry viii did quite a good good job of
he executed his wives tom
yes have you cleared that with your wife
because
well
henry vii let's go with his father his
father created the navy
uh charles ii restored the monarchy
there have been a lot of kings they all
monarchs are just fit for their age
we've been very very lucky and of course
we look forward now to charles
and until recently with some trepidation
and i think what has been very very
fortunate is the transition from the
queen to charles has been taking place
over what one or two or three years now
so the sudden shock will not be the same
when he finally becomes king i think
he's also changed he's he's mellowed
he's not being as uh ostentatious and
self-indulgent as he was he's not
speaking out as he did before
and he's got a gravitas and i think the
queen very rightly from her point of
view said that camilla should be the
next queen yeah i agree and i've and
that that means that the transition will
be smooth yes i agree
have you met them i think camilla gets a
bad rap she's a terrific lady i think
she's actually they're great together
and i think they'll be very good for the
country so tom thank you very much thank
you to my stellar panel really
appreciate it